[Music]
how do you vet
how do you choose blockchain crypto
investments because there is
so much out there there's this paradox
of choice
how do you choose things yeah at this
point are there any particular check
boxes or criteria yeah 100 so
the way that i think about it is that
first you have to say
where have we been and where are we
going and so when you start off the kind
of where we've been we've been when
these chains first launched they had one
utility they were like a store of value
and a way to send digital currency to
and from one wallet to another right
that was bitcoin for the first few years
and now when you think about where we're
going
there are just a whole slew of different
arenas that this blockchain technology
has been applied to
so you know you have decentralized
exchanges
you have you know the nfts that we
talked about in marketplaces around that
um all the web three kind of censorship
resistant communication protocols you
have
insanely high performance protocols are
blockchains like solana and some of the
others that are out there and they could
do 50 000 transactions per second and so
what gets unlocked when you have that
type of speed operating on a blockchain
then you have existing big behemoth
block chains like ethereum and like how
we're gonna scale ethereum in the short
term so you talk about what they're
called layer two scaling solutions the
entire financial stack is being
rewritten from the ground up so thinking
about what is the future of checking and
savings accounts what does it mean to
stream money to people in real time and
how does that work and so you know
there's a world where a startup pitches
not just recently where they figured out
a way to stream money to people in real
time and so what that means is rather
than going into work and like clocking
in and you know waiting two weeks to get
paid
you clock in and money hits your account
every you know 25 to 30 seconds
in real time as it's being earned and so
there's just like this complete
rethinking of of of the distribution
of of financial assets so you know what
once was
if you let me pull up like wells fargo
right now but if you pull up like a big
bank and you say wells fargo wikipedia
and you take a look at the head count
that they have to
uh employ to pull off a traditional
so they have 72
hundred branches in 2021 13 000 atms
and 268
000 employees
for wells fargo
so think about what that payroll must
look like yeah it's a lot of mouth
surgery a lot of amounts of feed and
that bloat that is in the financial
system and so what do you get in return
you have a checking savings account you
get some fdic insurance which is nice
and you get absolutely nothing you get
no interest
like i get that it's nice that they
handle fraud on the check side and you
know there's there's a phone number to
call and all of that but
all of that money
that is that they're taking your money
and lending it out on your behalf behind
the scenes
and you know their revenue for 2020
was
72.34 billion dollars for 2020.
so
that money now in a decentralized
fashion on the blockchain where
now you have some of these people
writing things like of a some of these
lending platforms or you have like a
block fi that is partially centralized
and partially decentralized
you
have these new banks and new financial
institutions and these new protocols
that are emerging
that take just a handful of people to
write code
manage and operate and then all of that
wealth transfer or wealth creation is
being distributed back to
the individual so i'm excited for the
future of finance because i think that
you know i mean like for example
you know you know i've talked about
block five before yeah you and i have
talked quite a bit about it yes in block
five for example um zach i had the ceo
on my show
we talk about
what they're really good at is is these
interest accounts that give people real
like insane interest at right now i
think it's like seven point five percent
right now on stable coins
which is just nuts like what are you
gonna get from bank if you keep a
hundred dollars in your block five
account and then i don't mean this to be
an ad for block five i'm not gonna put
any affiliate code anywhere and anything
in tim's show notes or anything but it's
like it's it's essentially it it's just
they're giving you seven percent on your
money on these on these table coins
which are us dollar coins which don't
change you want to worry about them
going up or going down because they're
able to go out and pass that that
savings they don't have that massive
overhead that a traditional bank would
have and they just pass it right back to
the end consumer and so a lot of these
platforms whether it be compound or ave
or some of these platforms you can go
and bring your cryptocurrency in you can
lend it back to the platform and you'll
get paid interest back to your wallet um
which is just awesome it's it's nice to
see that finally going back to the
consumers versus just being kept by the
big banks
you